[Music]
it's alright this week we've got nap
tents unusual punishment and funeral
crasher
take it away TIFF okay for our first
story I feel like Bart's might really
like this product we're about to talk
about farts what is it oh tent Napper
how'd you know just kidding I was like
what the [ __ ] I did I know yeah there's
this new product it's called pause pod
and I'm gonna show you guys a little
clip of their crowdfunding page the
IndieGoGo page
I tripped out cuz you went pause but I
heard Pau
so you went like this pop pod I think
that's [ __ ] cool there's like
something to pause oh like bear and then
pause yeah I'm and then with a map a
berry map we reinvented it through this
thing
hibernation tents yeah I thought it was
dogs here we go
definitely need a [ __ ] tip for that
kid it is a crazy ass lady
[Music]
did they mean to be invisible like that
[Laughter]
[Music]
you can just do that on the carpet oh oh
he's oh those are his legs yeah they
were it was such a good concept and they
somehow [ __ ] it all up that like
attachment for his leg so this is a part
in its little it's massive
yes portable pause pod where you can
take anywhere you want to take a nap
anywhere you want I should have made it
into a backpack that makes the most
sense what the [ __ ]
no saw it also includes a reading or the
like additional add-ons is like a
reading light and a waterbed version of
it no it's space for you to put your
iPad so you could watch it like on top
of the tent and then I don't really like
products that tell people to kick your
ass
like I don't like yeah right yeah like
when you if you carry that you're
telling the world
can you please [ __ ] and I'm not a big
fan of any products like that like
roller bags for example it's I [ __ ] me
up like would you would date a guy that
like walks in and like if you want to go
grab some coffee and it took this big
yeah that's sexy just a guy working
inside one of these he's got a big dick
at that yeah sexy guy we should have
called this a portable [ __ ] tent
you can't even [ __ ] though is it that
small its height look it's only one
person yeah I'd make it work so let's go
back to the other picture go back see if
that guy remove that right had a cafe
racer or something he looks saying he'd
be attractive yeah but you take the cafe
racer away and you got to [ __ ] me up to
bag on them not almost the beat is ass
it looks like a target what if you had a
camera on him in a hot model next time
because this we know what this looks
like it looks like one of those
reflector BAM yeah he's like the
portable wardrobe changing thing for the
model
that's what this could be use for
changing but you got a change on your
knees
yeah yeah that's true or on your back
with your legs yeah they [ __ ] it all
up like it's a good I see where they're
trying to get out and it's good but
whoever designed it and Everett the
whole team that approved it you guys
just kind of it's so unnecessary so
coming from someone that takes naps all
the time it's super unnecessary because
it's doing way too much all you really
need is those boasts sound headphones
and in something to put over your eyes
and that's literally where you can take
a nap anywhere that's their other add on
the mini pause so they have this like
sleeping mask that have you ear oh my
god that's all you need cuz any other
situation it's not like it makes the
floor softer or anything like that or
just you just look like an idiot in the
middle of a library that guy it's a
portable [ __ ] can we use that hole my
not [ __ ] going take a break from my
[ __ ] family and now everyone could
talk [ __ ] you could still hear that holy
God
George is such a [ __ ] loser hey guys
they actually have in the video where
he's setting up his pause pod right in
front of him
well we named it his wife get in a
[ __ ] fight like sleep in your [ __ ]
pause pod
oh is it that you're trying to sing oh
no I mean do you guys think it would be
better if it was bigger no it's too big
it's already too big if it was bigger
I'll just be a 10
yeah because it's just like the link
sticking out from there like I mean he
goes a little bigger wouldn't look so
weird but well maybe that's their
demographic oh yeah would you write it
no don't screw here this show it's that
it's not made out of lead you wanna be
like this being feathers right on the
bottom it's not like oh [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] loud as [ __ ] in here guys oh ho
it's so [ __ ] quiet now this doesn't
do [ __ ] yeah
yeah you [ __ ] like concrete or steel
or something
so to give a little credit they did you
do like a little test where it's their
material with my typical tense material
and their material like the light
doesn't shine through it at all so I
guess if you wanted to take like a
pitch-black nap out and weak and like in
a park or something I guess you could do
out of the middle the 405 freeway we
just don't [ __ ] hear the trucks
driving by no light thing right I'm
trying to get a little credit here
does it come in different color you
can't give them credit because you just
pointed out how he [ __ ] set up in his
bed they [ __ ] up the market Eve a
little lost a little bit so there are
some reactions to this and there's one
that really cracked me up so well first
of all this is their IndieGoGo they've
raised a hundred and forty-one thousand
go for you as [ __ ] up as your [ __ ] is
you still did a good job well there's
probably geniuses out there that can see
a use that I can't see so I'm good for
them and you're gonna be able to utilize
this thing yeah so some reactions this
one's my favorite do you like tents but
feel like you weren't tripping enough
people that's pretty funny this pod pod
it allows you to nap anywhere canceling
out that giant bed right behind you oh
my god is that an ad that's there I
didn't see that that was in the earlier
after the video that video it's like a
2-3 minute long video so I'm we got it
oh this part is in that video though but
not the part that I showed you it
I believe so anyways moving on you guys
the puss pod is just a laundry hamper
with a man eating a banana inside don't
be fooled yeah oh yeah it is a laundry
hamper yeah that's a few monkeys logic
oh my god
that's what it could be used for hunting
okay well what is the black band out in
the hole like would you well they can't
they can't see if you want to be a
pervert yeah tell the lion CVO starts
charging you and your [ __ ] with your
[ __ ] there's only enough space for him
to sit cross-legged yeah so they're
trying to promote this to like for
people that meditate they can meditate
anywhere well the point of meditation is
supposed to you're supposed to just do
it anywhere and block everything out
exactly yeah you're you're you're a
better meditator by being able to block
it out right easily you know this is
cheating yeah yeah no but this one you
want to read it okay
all around me are familiar - all around
me okay I know the song put your
blessings okay so anyways moving on to
the next story there was this woman in
China so she works in this company and
apparently this company has a rule that
everyone must wear their seatbelts
when they drive and so she what a roll
no wait does the company have anything
to do with the driver that's the thing I
don't know what company she works
because I'll be funny if they work at a
paper mill but they're like regulation
is you have to wear a seatbelt well it
looks like she just works in an office
but I don't know what kind of company so
it's not even a national law that you
have to worry per well probably but I'm
just not gonna go into that okay it
probably is it in China yeah cuz I saw
so many people not worried huh oh then
maybe I don't know but for this
particular office it was a rule that
they must wear seatbelts and this woman
she was driving into work and her boss
saw her without a seat belong and this
or punishment oh yeah China you guys are
[ __ ] awesome that's so cool I don't
care I think she knew the rules y'all
fall Susan you didn't wear your seatbelt
they're just ignoring her ass yeah
that's a JK party game
how can we do that for party whoo we get
duct tape all up to the wall and see if
we can like get out and football can't
play because I was making it up that was
one of the rules and so as her
punishment it was stated that she would
get taped up to the wall for how long
I'm not sure for how long but these are
a couple of rules that they mention in
this article so the whole not driving
without a seat belt you get cool the
other one that makes sense a good core
theological punishment you know oh they
didn't make it up on a spot like that
was what was gonna happen to you yeah so
if you don't wear your seat belt you're
gonna get taped to the weight on it out
it's already in the rule book so they
had the tape ready to go I wish I was at
that meeting when they were deciding
like what punishment goes with that
what other punishment would you come up
with I mean I can't talk [ __ ] that
all right that's creative yeah it's like
a whole committee like HR and everyone
gets together so welcome to the annual
meeting of crime and punishment for rows
unrelated to our job or maybe there are
maybe there is like like a reason why
they do it like they don't want their
employees to get hurt like rules of
conduct I mean there's gotta be does
that sound like China though that they
care about their employees I think the
laws aren't enough so the companies have
to go beyond that to make like better
standards for their employees I think so
pretty positive what about these other
world next rule is it's as female
workers are allowed to take a sick leave
when they have periods male workers can
do so if their girlfriends have periods
this is China
no that's what I'm saying this company
probably is trying very hard yeah their
company culture because that's the only
way it makes sense but because they're
still Asian they go about it in an Asian
way so it's like forced
progress instead of like we're trying to
make the world a better place it's not
that's not option no it's not optional
we're trying to force you to be better
if you don't [ __ ] do this what's the
punishment for that they don't mention
it's already punishment enough that you
gotta go to working hours are 11:00 a.m.
to 5:00 p.m. what 11:00 a.m. that's
crazy
for an Asian company I thought it'd be
like 4:00 a.m. or something in the park
any late comers or early levers will
have to crawl out of the office well I
would love to but we live in California
and people seem like a [ __ ] it's
a joke if you make those like sign a
waiver thing where you can't sue us
because this is a joke you can't they
still sue some nothing
California takes all the fun out of
everything let's pretend that we didn't
live in California
what would you will we live in China
yeah we moved JK to China what kind of
rules that you have give me three months
to brainstorm oh man any any video any
video that's not over a million views
everyone gets stung by bees there's
never my phone it has to be it has to be
something that helps people cuz in this
company it's like you're helping people
be better yeah what would be your rule
if you come early too early for work
then you have to buy everybody food all
speaking how would everyone else benefit
from this no it has to be something
completely illogical so if you come
earlier to work and it's like then you
have to dress like a donkey or something
but there's kind of law or you have to
just like a bird early bird early bird
you have to eat worms early brackets
the earliest one to work has to eat a
worm you missed our moment I heard it I
repeated it you missed my moment story
there's this woman in the UK that for
the last 14 years she's been a funeral
crasher in her church so for the last 14
years every single wake that has
happened in that church she will go to
the funeral and try to hit on guy she
like she'll leave her home in her
regular clothes and she has like a black
dress in her in her crazy Wow we shall
get to the church put on her black dress
hit up the free buffet put some food in
her Tupperware and then take off and
she's been doing this for the last 14
years and people around in her community
or just like what the [ __ ] lady
yeah yeah she's like a super villain
that crashes who knows she's the food
she can get into a costume and
everything in her defense though at
funerals no one really has an appetite
so there is food leftover true unless
you're like a morning eater a morning
eater or a sad eater yes sandy sandy
there's only gonna be like me and David
eating and then everyone else there's
always food leftover so she is kind of
doing I never understood the food at a
funeral thing like why it's a farewell
party
you have like full-on food yeah yeah my
wife did the way they do in the movies
at least the white people in the movies
it's like a party like chicken parmesan
Barca roasted eggplant she's not Asian
she's at home how dad this woman she
don't get no [ __ ] she really don't give
no [ __ ] cuz like even the pastor's like
oh I can't tell her not to come [ __ ] yet
tell this [ __ ] nautical right she looks
like she's doing she gave me the forward
as she needs food no I mean they're also
saying that there was this one time
where a witness that she saw her show up
and she put on her dress she realized
that there was no food and she took it
off
you just wrote off on her bike like all
like disgusted like she made a disgusted
face like people as in like a bicycle
yeah you pictured a motorcycles grandma
just riding a bicycle and then having
her like little bells I go she has a
basket there reporter she has a little
basket and she'll put a Tupperware yeah
yeah and this is the church that she
goes to oh so she only frequents that
church this church she finds out the
funeral schedule so the priest was
saying that she she somehow got this
idea in her head that she must attend as
many masses as she could possibly
attempts over the last 14 years as long
as this priest has been there she's been
going to every single mass at that
church has cluding the funerals and then
also at the funerals she'll pretend like
she knew the person that passed so this
one Haven was when this woman she had
passed away and the woman's mother was
at the funeral and Theresa was saying
like oh yeah it was I was uh I knew her
when we were both waitressing back in
the day and then she's like my daughter
never did waitressing ever so she was
just like making up stories like that
she knows these people back in a day
when her daughter was like 13 years old
and [ __ ] maybe given her age she's just
kind of like lost it a little bit I like
her she's pretty cool I think it'd be a
different story if she went and was just
crying to be with people I'd be like
okay that's kind of sweet I mean yeah
the part that really paints her as shady
and my book is the fact that she was all
disgusted when people didn't have food
it should just bounce like what the hell
my god has nothing to do with the math
or anything or maybe she was angry like
how can you not have food at this
funeral because you should have food for
your loved ones like she has her set of
standards it's not for her of course
it's our funerals private parties like
the they can shoo them away if you want
right well I don't know if it's at a
church I don't know if you can well no
one knows that she's not a part of the
funeral cuz she's like pretending and so
much people ask her then she like runs
away oh maybe you think you don't wake I
think it is a week let's use crashing
club news assuming I
let's say there's like a like all Asian
funeral lady pops out I think it's
easier for a family like that like hey
she doesn't belong to the hell out of
here right versus if it's like not all
Asian
I guess you to why they wouldn't kick
her out it's like everyone's so
vulnerable it's just like you're not
even thinking of this at random old lady
so they should just leave food out like
she's a pigeon all right at this church
I know you guys gonna have catering but
let's just make a little like a three
item special for her put it off to the
side so she's even have to come in it's
like the neighborhood stray cat maybe
you don't even have to put on your black
dress here you go howdy do folks thank
you so much for watching don't forget to
subscribe to stay up on their most
recent upload and any other cool content
that we put up there and hit the
subscribe button for the last video
click up here
[Music]